there's
yeah
and they're going to live stream in on
our website
hope that's clean
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey that's like one two three four five
five four three two one
tim
symansky s-z-y-m-a-n-s-k-i
las vegas fire and rescue
so at 3 25 this morning we had a report
of a fire and a three-story senior
residency high-rise
it eventually went to a three-alarm
smoke was showing from a second-story
balcony of the three-story building
fire lapping up to the third floor
second and third floors were evacuated
the bus was brought in to house those
seniors
while the firefighters put it out
they were able to confine it to the two
apartments the fire started on the
second floor
on the balcony
of one apartment and lapped up to the
balcony of the apartment and extended to
that unit on the third floor
it was confined to the two units in the
hallway on the second floor
150 000 damage
we have no injuries in connection with
this incident
and the cause of the fire appears to be
smoking related
the occupant says that
they did smoke on the balcony late last
night before going to bed the fire
investigator says that the patterns
found on the balcony are consistent with
the fire originating around where the
smoking material she says that she was
smoking so it's accidental
nobody hurt
crews are picking up
returning to their stations
there were no injuries in connection
with the incident
we have a lot of people who have
mobility issues on wheelchairs how lucky
are we that we have no injuries at all
when it appears that this the hallway
was completely uh smoke filled
and a lot of these people have hearing
issues the fire alarms
did go off these doors are made to
withstand fire and smoke
and
a lot of them we had to wake them up and
the firefighters had to
take them out
by that time we were already starting to
take smoke out of the building so
actually with the doors closed they were
like sheltering in place
and it was probably a blessing in the
skies and that
by those people staying in their units
they didn't go into the smoke field
hallway which could have caused more
injury so it worked out really well
i was talking with the resident was
telling me that she was in her unit
crying stuck unable to get out until
just out of nowhere firefighter
firefighters rushing and takerash was so
thankful
your thoughts
well on these newer buildings it's
little boxes that are put together to
make a big box
and if every if the conditions are right
the fire should be confined to the one
box where the
fire originated
so
the best place for you to be if you
can't get out if you open the door and
you find
the hallway full of smoke is close the
door
the door is one of the best piece
equipment fire safety equipment in a
building
it keeps fire and smoke out and
especially in buildings like this
those are extra special doors they're
much thicker it can hold back so what it
did it did what it was supposed to do it
kept those elements from going in there
they were sheltering in place and they
were probably in the best place possible
the fire's not going to go through the
wall
very rarely we would have hoses already
up there
and many times we do tell people to
shelter in place because
you are better in that room than you are
anyplace else so it's always important
to do what the firefighters
tell you to do they wouldn't evacuate
those residents until we feel that the
hallway is safe enough for them to
evacuate through
it's a complex for low income complex
for seniors
that's what i understand
you know i'm not sure if it's even for
seniors and that but but in any event
this this went really well went to a
third alarm
which means that we probably got about
40 pieces of equipment with about 100
firefighters on scene
if you give me just one second guys i
can tell you for sure
you know a few questions this is
you guys train all year for
situations like this
we're so fortunate to be able to you
know have no injuries
like two stars happen
but like if you want to talk about the
training and what you guys go through
to make sure
you guys prevent any uh bandwidth or any
injuries like that
i don't have those little things up
there like that you see you know
everything worked well uh this is
when we give classes to the public
especially in high-rises
everything that was supposed to happen
happened here this morning
again we tell people when you're leaving
check the hallway first if the hallway
is completely filled with smoke
don't escape close the door
put a towel down at the bottom of the
floor
call 9-1-1 and tell them
what room you're in
so they can tell us on the fire ground
so we can send firefighters up there
to retrieve you
but again even in your regular home in
your apartment set
closed doors saves lives so you should
sleep with your door closed go into your
room so if a fire starts it keeps the
smoke out it slows down the progression
of fire
in homes
and buildings like this here in hotels
and at the doors are much thicker
they're better quality than the average
home they can fight back to fire for
longer
amounts of time
so
make sure you have smoke alarms in your
house
the alarms did work here
probably had some people that had some
hearing
problems but the firefighters did get
them out
they were evacuated to a shelter
they're returning back to their
apartments now i don't have a count on
how many people are displaced but most
likely it's just going to pertain to
those two apartments
to help
folks
yeah we're
we're going to go in and do an
assessment now to find out how many
apartments are not
compatible for people staying in there
right now and we'll work that out with
management the red cross
okay thank you tim thanks guys